all right
uh
awesome it worked
av worked for once in our life
cool uh so welcome everybody um i'm
going to be talking about a lot of
basically the
um methodologies and practices that we
do at bitly to
uh move quickly without breaking the
internet because
non-trivial amount of that goes to our
servers
uh so before i get into the meat of that
let me get something out of the way that
tends to come up with bitly so just our
curiosity how many people here are aware
of at least bitly in the form of like
short links right
awesome cool
um
a lot of times that gets just like
really seriously how is that a company
right like i can literally write a url
shortener before i'm you're done with
this talk how is that a thing
um it's just child's play come on and
even then how do you make money off of
it like even if i grant that like doing
this with high availability and doing a
large scale is difficult like how do you
possibly make money off of short links
well short answer is branding so we have
tools for basically having companies
host
their own url shorteners through us
as so you can see there
espn links those are us
uh and analytics uh so every click that
goes through bitly we do a bunch of
tracking and we do a bunch of number
crunching
to uh keep track of what's going on
so let's talk from a technical
perspective about what actually kind of
challenges we're dealing with so every
single day we see 200 million redirects
20 million shortens
we crawl about 4 million pages on the
web
just to roll that up for some people
that works out to about six billion
clicks a month
uh we do that with about 400 servers
spread across two data centers with 25
engineers doing 20 plus deploys every
day
right so that's a lot of change going
out all the time um so let's get into
kind of how we think about that and how
we deal with that and some of the
challenges involved right
um
so when you talk about doing something
like 20 deploys every day
there's a tension that's going on there
right
on one hand you want to be keeping
things
safe right if those short links that we
have all over the web like at this point
there are literally tens of billions of
bitly links
and it's embedded throughout the web
right so if those break
nobody's happy right like that's a
really bad day people are pissed off
right
um
it's it's really no good i've been there
when we had outages it's it's bad
um the flip side is we need to ship
things quickly right i mean a just like
at the end of the day be frank we're vc
back startup right either we grow and
learn or die that's just how the
business works
we have competitors and we have stuff we
want to do ourselves and that our
customers want so we have to keep
shipping stuff
um so leads to these really conflicting
desires because a lot of way a lot of
things you do to move quickly
test to break stuff right like the the
classic facebook like move fast and
break right like that's
that's a problem for us
um
so this is going to be talking about
basically
it's just going to be kind of like a
shotgun of stuff we do to deal with that
um and at the top of the list is
automation we automate
everything and a lot of it is just
because if we didn't we would break down
crying
there's just no way this stuff can work
without it
uh so of those 400 servers i mentioned
200 of those are in ec2 and at that
scale we get an email at least once a
week saying hey your server's going to
go away in a few weeks and then there's
probably another one or two that just go
away without any warning right like
that's a thing that we have to deal with
if we were manually replacing and
provisioning those servers we would need
an army of systems which just isn't
practical both in terms of like salaries
that we can pay as well as just like a
thing to manage right like that's just
nuts
um
another part of why we automate
everything is just computers are faster
right a lot of the at the end of the day
a lot of what
traditional systems do
is fairly kind of rope mechanical work
right like 90 of provisioning a server
is just doing the same things over and
over and over again and not messing up
computers are a lot better at doing that
and doing it quickly right so as an
example
uh right now for us and we haven't
actually spent a whole lot of time
optimizing this for us to go from making
the api request to
provision an ec2 server to something
live handling production data is about
10 minutes
if somebody were to do all the work that
happens in that process manually you're
talking about at least a day of somebody
being completely focused on that work
and they probably are going to mess
something up in that process
which kind of gets to the next part of
why we really like automation is
computers are a lot more consistent than
humans right
they have limitations as far as like
pattern recognition and flexibility but
if you give them the same inputs and the
same environment to work in
it's really really likely that they're
going to do exactly what they did
yesterday today right
um so that generally is a nice attribute
and that i can trust that the script
that i did ran yesterday is going to
work the same today
but that gets really powerful when you
have a solid review and testing process
in place
right so there's a certain amount that i
can do review and testing with humans
but since they're fuzzy and they're not
going to perfectly duplicate things
every time
just because somebody deployed something
yesterday i'm not going to be super
confident that they're going to get it
perfect today on the other hand if i
have a script that went through a review
process and worked in dev and worked in
staging and worked in production
yesterday i'm super confident that
assuming the environment hasn't changed
it's going to work exactly the same
today which can be really powerful for
basically getting stuff done quickly
and then
taking things beyond deployment we
really take automation throughout
everything so this is jenkins
um for us we actually have a bit like a
little
process so as i'll get into we use
github pull requests for
basically all of our code review
so anytime code gets pushed to an open
pull request the jenkins
jenkins will run
our automated tests against that code
it's one of those things that makes it
makes a lot of information available to
people very quickly that otherwise would
take a lot more time
additionally operational tasks um
pretty much anytime you know the first
time we might do we do a particular
operational task like let's say
um
i don't know
expanding the
resources available to a database or
something we might do that manually by
the second time we do it we automate it
because at that point it's very likely
that there'll be a third time in a
fourth time in the fifth time
and
we're lazy
right um the classic you know good
developers are lazy developers and they
don't want to do things a bunch of times
we very much take that to heart
especially for operational tasks
uh something else that we think about a
lot at bitly is state management
so i have a better story around this so
about a year and a half ago when i was
first interviewing at bitly uh something
that came up and the conversations will
generally come up in like a technical
interview is a question of how they
manage kind of their their stm like how
they manage code code control
and it came up in that conversation that
bitly manages all their code both
systems code and basically configuration
management code
practical purposes imagine chef and
puppet uh in one giant monolithic repo
and at first i was like what that sounds
insane how is that not a giant rat's
nest where you can't find anything and
manage anything
but we talked about it for a bit and
that kind of came around to
well this isn't so bad right
uh if you have some practices in place
that
uh
enforce some discipline so that
you know you can basically manage that
that tendency for things to decay into a
rat's nest
you get this really powerful side effect
of having a unified view of the world of
code and config being joined
any given commit in our repository is a
complete snapshot of the state of our
system minus data
so that's really powerful as far as if
you're trying to either go back in time
and figure out what things were going on
or if you need to do a rollback or
bailout of a bad deploy
um you don't have to go through and
figure out like okay what like you know
i don't know how many have gone through
like okay we did deploy things are
really bad we have to roll back right
the first step in that is like okay
where do we roll back to because it's
not necessarily the last commit
if you have things coming from a dozen
repos you have to do that a dozen times
now which
is not exciting when things are on fire
if you have everything in one repo you
can kind of just roll back and there are
some scaling
limitations with that but
a quirk we found from talking to people
was like this is actually how to a
certain degree google and facebook also
do things right like and for much of the
same reasons
um so you have some kind of interesting
benefits there
the next really fundamental way we look
at things that has
deep implications for everything we do
is service oriented architecture
so
if you look at bitly from a code
perspective there is no one bitly
application there are dozens of little
services that focus on particular tasks
that then tie together in relatively
loose ways
to make the system overall
and this gives us a ton of nice benefits
we also cheat a little bit in making
that easier for us but
i'm not going to talk about that too
much in this talk um
so one of the biggest things for us is
what failure looks like in the context
of soa
if in a monolithic application what
tends to happen is
if there's some let's say there's a bad
deploy and let's say there's some kind
of configuration problem where you can't
talk to caching or something like that
right your entire system goes down hard
down
in the soa setup since you have
isolation between these different
services and very specific boundaries
between them it's extremely unlikely
that you'll take down the entire system
most of the time will happen is you'll
just
have a particular service go down and
you'll certainly have a degraded user
experience right a particular feature
won't work but the servers overall will
keep going
um which is really important for us
because again not breaking the internet
uh another nice side effect of this kind
of setup is when we do a deploy like one
of those 20 plus deploys a day
we're
never deploying to all 400 servers at
once aside from the actual like
computational task that's involved which
is non-trivial on that
uh that's potentially a very
destabilizing thing to do
but since everything is broken down into
services where there's specific hardware
handling different services we only need
to deploy to the servers where
uh
the service runs
sure um so the question was um
if we have one big repo for all of our
code but uh we only want certain bits of
that code running on any given server
how do we figure that out
um
the practical answer to that is while we
have one big repo we organize things
within that repo there's basically
a bunch of top-level directories and
those top-level directories are
basically services so there's no
cross-communication or library sharing
between those aside from through normal
system stuff so muscle ourselves python
so there's something that needs to be
shared across services like it gets
installed as a python package through
our deploy process and that's how that
gets shared
um and then basically we have it
our configuration management system is
homegrown in this crazy pile of bash in
python for practical server purposes
from a high high enough
level you can think of it as chef and
puppet and basically we have a system of
tags for the servers so kind of like
rolls and chef and i imagine puppet has
something similar i haven't worked that
with it that much to basically say these
are the services that should run in this
particular box and based on that it will
kind of start up or tear down services
accordingly is that
cool
um
another really powerful aspect of
service oriented architecture is it
makes everything easier to understand
both when you're debugging and when
you're architecting systems i think you
can think of this as like um
functions and classes in your code right
like while you technically could write
whatever application you're going to
write is just one giant
pile of
you know serially executing code
you'll go insane trying to figure keep
track of anything longer than a few
hundred lines right
so we have these abstractions that allow
you to
isolate functionality into specific
little pieces and then either pay
attention to
how the pieces fit together or the
implementation inside of one individual
piece but not having to keep the whole
picture in your head at once
similarly services give you a similar
kind of
abstraction
in that you can either look at a
systematic level right if you just know
if stuff's broken but i'm not sure what
is actually the problem you can look at
a system level to say what piece is
likely broken then when you figure out
that piece you can kind of
invert how you're looking at those api
boundaries and just look inside that
service and see what's going on which is
really really powerful for understanding
stuff uh one of the then this gets
takes things a step further as your code
base ages so bitly's been around for
about five years
there's a lot of code there and like
i've been there for a year and a half
and i still don't know all the code
right like it's just it's a lot but
that's okay because most of our services
are less than a few hundred lines on
their own so even if you've never
touched a service you can just dive into
it and understand it very quickly and
deal with that as you need to
another nice benefit of this setup is it
makes it very easy to use the right tool
for the right job
so as i've kind of alluded to our
default bitly is python just because
we like it we find it readable we can
develop in it quickly
but there's things that it's maybe not
always the best tool for right if you
have to do really complex concurrency
that is miserable in python if you have
to iterate over things really quickly
it's just not that good at it
um
so
when we run into situations where python
isn't the right tool for the right job
we can pull in other things very easily
because our
service boundaries are just kind of
platform agnostic right it's just json
either through http calls or
uh pub sub queues um so for example we
need something to be faster doing crazy
concurrency we tend to use go
we have a search system where lucine is
really appealing so we use java there
right we can just plug those in as we
need to
that has some other potential risks as
far as using all the tools and having to
figure keep that in your head but
with some discipline it's not so bad
excuse me
similarly we can use data stores
as it makes sense for a given service um
so part of the isolation between systems
is if they need to persist data they
each take care of that persistence on
their own so our data is massively
denormalized this is one of the ways we
can cheat and that our data is
effectively immutable since links don't
change and clicks don't change
um but there are ways to do this if you
do have more immutable data
but accordingly each service can have a
data store that makes sense on its own
so we have one service that's basically
a
metadata that we get from crawling pages
because doing the actual crawl is a
fairly expensive operation
um and that's basically just a key value
thing with billions of things right so
that kind of sounds like react so we
just use rock there
uh there's another service where we kind
of keep track of real-time click rates
on
uh
and there redis is a really good fit
because we want it to be fast we care
about
like it's nice to have those complex
data structures but the overall data
set's not going to be that big so it can
fit in memory so we've got to use the
right tool for the right job
similarly we can use uh suit hardware as
needed right like our default is
something that looks like a c1 medium or
i guess the new ones c3
large um on ec2 just because we've
optimized for cost performance on those
but some things need a lot of memory or
they need ssds right so we can build
things to accommodate like that
similarly we can make decisions as far
as
what data center runs as far as having
actual hardware versus the
virtualization
um
we can also scale services as needed
right so let's say
we make a change that means that we're
going to be crawling twice as many
things as we previously previously used
to we can just add more resources and
scale that scrolling service without
having to have anything else care about
that right since you have those
boundaries and separations of concerns
you can deal with those problems just
where
they happen without having to worry
about too many consequences to other
parts of the system
which again
when you're not worried about when you
have those clean isolations keeps things
stable
yep
uh right now we have tooling for ec2 and
so our we're in ec2 and we have a
uh effectively dedicated hardware within
a verisign data center that's our other
data center we potentially could move
into other clouds but we haven't built
the tooling for that
just curious what are you calling for
uh to get extra context on links uh so
from
just actual redirects that we do we get
some contacts just based on what the
browser sends as part of that redirect
process but we usually don't can't tell
what the page is about so we'll crawl a
bunch of pages and do a bunch of
analysis to say like what the topic of
this page is maybe pictures titles stuff
like that
and the last thing that we get from this
is
significant cost savings right by being
very
being
able to very
specifically tailor hardware and
optimizations to given sys particular
services that are focused on specific
tasks we can save a ton of money because
we're not spending having a bunch of
stuff sitting around not getting used
so we can kind of tailor things as it
needs to be tailored
the next thing that we think about is
async being better than synchronous
except when it isn't
at this point you might think
he's going to go into some tirade about
some hipster like node.js or
whatever
thankfully
we're talking at a different level uh
something more architectural right
when we look at building systems we try
and ask
can this look more like sending letters
in the mail than two people having a
conversation right because you get a
bunch of benefits by
having that that
different relationship between systems
um
in particular you get better isolation
and looser coupling right so
um
and
accordingly you get more flexibility
um and a lot of that comes down to what
ever and load situations look like right
so
um
let's say
uh you know our metric system that's
keeping track of like our time series
database that keeps track of how many
collects something has gotten a given
time period so that's having some kind
of capacity issue and i can't keep track
of just the stream of data coming at it
if you're dealing with some kind of
synchronous process
now suddenly that
capacity issue or that failure is a
problem for the upstream system that's
handling the redirects that's producing
the data for that system
but if you have things going through
something that's more asynchronous and
particularly something with cues
uh the upstream system doesn't need a
care right it can keep advertising the
that things have happened and the
downs and that can just pile up for a
while while the downstream system works
through whatever it needs to and they
can just work through that backlog as it
needs to
the gotcha here that situation of except
when it isn't is when you care a lot
about consistency
uh so kind of to give you a practical
example
when you shorten a link on bitly
everything that happens there at a
systematic level is completely
synchronous right so
um that goes through a bunch of layers
of our architecture and that's all
either http basically blocking http
calls or blocking database calls and the
reason for that is we care a ton about
consistency here right because we can't
give the same bitly hash to two
different long urls because that's kind
of like crossing the streams right like
just that doesn't work the universe kind
of ends
um
and similarly we much prefer to say hey
we had a problem we couldn't give you a
bitly link then to give you a bitly link
that doesn't work
you technically could do that in an
asynchronous way but keeping track of
all those failure scenarios gets much
more complicated and doing that in a
timely manner it gets much more
complicated we care about this being
very fast
on the other hand for metrics
incrementing
if there's a few seconds or maybe even a
minute of delay in updating our stats
pages
yeah
but on the other hand we care about
redirecting users really quickly right
so we don't if there's some problem in
our metric system we don't want to have
the redirects get slowed down or broken
right our metric system failing should
never be the reason that redirects don't
work
so
by pushing making that an asynchronous
process it makes it very easy to get
that isolation and that
kind of loose coupling between there
one of the other things that can be nice
kind of related to loose coupling is
when you have things to be asynchronous
it's very it's much easier to kind of
uh kind of tee off those streams to make
copies of them
which i'll get into a bit
so the way we actually go about doing a
lot of this asynchronous stuff at
architectural level is a system called
nsq
uh it's an open source distributed
messaging platform that
we've built and open uh released
uh you might be looking at hearing
distributed real-time messaging what on
earth does that actually mean
i'm not going to go super deep into it
but we can go through some features
um so nsq uses pub sub messaging
semantics you must you publish messages
to a topic and then you have can have
channels which you can kind of think of
it's like
uh copies of that topic for a given
purpose which then have a set of
consumers
uh it's distributed so there's no single
point of failure and there's no central
bottlenecks uh you don't need to worry
about having your ampq server fill up
and fall over because it's out of memory
or it's out of
erlang processes
similarly you don't have to worry about
like the physical nic card on a given
box getting saturated
you have some other gotchas in that like
there's no strong ordering but
depends on use case
uh the other thing that's nice here is
there's dynamic configuration so if
you're gonna add new channels or topics
that all happens at runtime you don't
have to worry about doing complicated
ordered deploys to manage that
um and as the name kind of suggests
there are queuing and messages so in
addition to those pub sub semantics as
i've kind of alluded to
uh if the consumers can't keep up with
the publishers it'll kind of just back
up for a while and you can set like high
water marks will go from memory onto
disk so that your server isn't falling
over because you used all the memory
which we've seen that can be
entertaining but unfortunate
and it also can have at least once
delivery guarantees there's a few
different kind of architectures that you
can do with nsq it's kind of like a
set of tools and there's different ways
you can use it but you can use in a way
where you have at least once guarantees
people sometimes ask about only ones
guarantees and that's kind of a
distributed systems problem if that's
not possible if you're interested we can
talk later
if you're interested in sq you can go
check it out on github um there's some
pretty solid documentation it's actually
a pretty decent community of people
using it in addition to us
and if you are want to talk about more
talk to me afterwards i'll hang out for
a while
the next thing that we think about when
we think about how do we
keep moving fast without breaking stuff
is user interfaces
user interfaces provide a few things
right they make things discoverable and
they make things accessible and they
give you the right info at the right
time
so here's some examples of that
we have something internally called
deploy ui we would open source it but
it's so specific to our weirdo
deployment system that doesn't make
sense it's really a thin wrapper around
our deployment system
um but it illustrates a lot of this
stuff nicely right for developers who
aren't necessarily
you know heads deep in opsworld
it makes it very easy for them to push
out code in a relatively safe way you
know you can just hear say uh it's not
working
awesome you can say what service you
want to deploy to what code you want to
push there right here you can just say
like i want this branch for this user
and it will auto populate pull requests
and give a comment about why you're
doing it because when you deploy and
things break it could be nice to have
that extra context
um and then also kind of give you a
recent history about deploys again is
nice if you're on call and suddenly get
a thousand nagios alerts saying hey the
world's broken if somebody just did a
deploy it might be related
um
similarly if you're about to go do an
employee and you see somebody's doing an
employee to the service that you're you
want to deploy to you should go probably
go talk to that person because you might
step on each other's toes so just a lot
of again write information the right
time and make it easy for people to do
things
another thing
that's a really big ui for us is fabric
i imagine most people in this audience
are familiar with it if not you can kind
of think of it as
bash over ssh with a bit of python mixed
in
um basically it's a very easy command
line interface for managing a bunch of
stuff remotely in a
procedural way
so that this deploy ui is actually just
a thin wrapper on top of the deploy
command within our fabric
setup
there's a bunch of other common
operational tasks that you can do
through fabric as far as like taking
stuff out of the low balance or whatnot
this is kind of you can think of as
affordance different people want to work
in different ways so maybe some people
to deploy to the ui some people do
deploy through fabric
it just makes sense for different people
nsq has a very nice admin that is also
open source
again you can kind of think of the right
info at the right time so this is
looking at the page for a topic so you
can see
what servers are producing given topic
you can kind of see some stuff out of
graphite as far as q depths and stuff
like that pretty much if any of these
lines are going up and to the right
something's probably broken
and you can drill down into the channels
again you can see individual consumers
and you can have the right context on
whether or not something's broken or if
something is broken where specifically
the problem is
and you can do some operational tests in
here which are convenient right so let's
say you're killing a system um nobody's
going to be consuming this topic anymore
you can kill those servers and delete
the topic through here
on the channel screen you can also do
stuff like pause channels
so let's say you want to do some kind of
database maintenance where you'd be nice
to not have any rights going on
you can just pause the channel be
confident that all the rights going into
that system are
not getting dropped but not going into
the system do your maintenance and then
resume the channel and
the world is good
again right information right time tools
to make things easier to use
we use the github
status api commit status
api so like i said for all all open pull
requests we have jenkins does a build
and when it does that build it reports
it back into github so when you're
looking at that pull request in a code
review you can see oh hey jenkins says
your stuff is broken
fix that
right so this goes a long way to helping
us not
um merge broken code and it makes it
really easy for us to be lazy right
nobody wants to have to like when
they're doing the code review remember
to go over to jenkins see if the build
worked then come back right this way
they can just see is it green or not
it's great
uh sorry it's titling the bits there
something else that we did recently so
as i imagine a bunch of you have either
seen or even dealt with there's been
somebody going around giving some
extortion threats and uh doing denial
service attacks
we got some of those
um so we have a bunch of disaster
recovery plans one of things we learned
in that process is that when it's four
o'clock in the morning and you're groggy
and you just got paid saying the world's
broken
you might take you a while to figure out
where all the stuff is to engage the
disaster recovery plans so we built
something called the red button at ui
this makes it really easy to a wake up
the rest of the ops team to help out and
then b engage the disaster recovery plan
yeah again making things easy and this
was something that one of our engineers
built in like two or three days right
using the tools that we already had so
it doesn't need to be anything crazy or
complicated but especially if you're
going down the path of automating as
much as you can it makes it really easy
to build these things as you need them
uh
the next big piece of how we do things
is peer review
like i mentioned we use github pretty
heavily
and a lot of the process around this is
kind of interesting in that
this is one of those places where you
can run into the danger getting into
this really draconian
heavy-handed like heavy process stuff
but we have just one rule
that everything else falls out from as a
side effect it's only one formal rule
and that is if you wrote the code you
are not allowed to hit that green button
right
so this has a bunch of wonderful side
effects my favorite of which is it moves
the worst problems that you have around
this kind of stuff to better places
right
when it's the end of the day and
somebody pushed out a change that broke
and you just need to push out a one-line
change to fix it yep
uh potentially so it depends on what's
going on um
it's
i mean we definitely do have the
attitude of while we have an on-call
rotation which is a fixed set of people
if your code breaks you're getting a
phone call
potentially uh
we are i get kind of where i was going
with that is culturally for us it's very
okay to wake up other people if you need
to
um
the other side is for certain scales of
changes it's okay to push out code that
hasn't been merged yet
a lot of times we'll soak
code in production as part of our
validation steps before it gets merged
the idea here is that master should
always be
safe right so if we a lot of times most
of the time the answer when somebody
does get paid in the morning it's not a
code change it's a rollback
right and part of how we can do that at
4 o'clock in the morning without
somebody else there is trusting that
master is safe
this is how hard we guarantee that
um but in the case where there are other
people around and we do have that one
lane change to fix stuff that you
probably have a typo in because there's
always one in a one-line change
this moves us to a better place instead
of pushing it out and making stuff worse
your problem now is to find somebody in
the office tap them on the stroller say
look at this
they'll find the typo you fix it and
then you push it out right it makes it a
better situation
um
something that you might have noticed is
the title slide for this section was
peer review and not code review
and the reason for that is we
the scope for the review is wider than
just the code
um we'll we'll take a lot of operational
and architectural concerns as part of
that review
so
a lot of times what we'll do i mean
obviously it depends on the scale of the
change some changes are just minor code
changes don't have any operational
changes involved awesome great easy
when let's say you're launching a new
system
we'll actually enumerate any kind of
operational tasks that are involved in
having that system go out as checklists
as part of the code review and when
somebody's reviewing that code
they are signing off both on the process
that's proposed as well as the code
itself
this has saved us a ton of headaches and
time
uh kind of examples of that is anytime
where rolling out something actually has
some kind of order like the order
dependencies this is really good for
flushing sure
do you find that since you're doing that
many proposals a day that you're less
likely to have errors because you're
deploying such small incremental changes
at a time yes
yeah no i mean uh that's something yeah
i don't highlight very well here i guess
explicitly but um
we are very much of the attitude that
ideally deploy should be non-events
right i deploy should be as small as
possible therefore they're going to
least likely things therefore they're
not scary right um there's some more
stuff we do kind of in that vein but yes
you're saying is it like some type of
structure or because of how you have
that set up that anyone really has
uh everybody has the ability to deploy
pretty much right away we do some
permissioning around
uh in that deploy ui you basically we do
have some permissioning controls about
what service people can deploy to
uh but we are fairly liberal about
opening it up as people need so it's
more a
making sure you can't make easy
accidents as opposed to preventing
people from doing stuff
um generally our attitude is things
should be as self-service as possible
um this also gets to our next point is
since all these code reviews and this is
a little bit of cheating over our size
right so bitly overall is about a 50
company of that's about 20 engineers so
enough people where if you go on
vacation it's not a problem but uh you
know big enough where you know everybody
and you keep track of roughly what
everybody's doing
um but since these pull requests are
open to everybody
they're also a really good mechanism for
cross-team sharing
um most of the time as something's going
on especially if it has ops implications
even somebody on my team cut the
application engineering kind of thing
back into business logic
um most of the time somebody from ops
will at least look over it and make sure
there's no like oh hey hey uh that's
gonna cause problems let's talk about
that right like so yep
so you said how many engineers
uh
we don't
really make that distinction right so so
the way we handle that is uh
we have what we call our office
infrastructure team so they
they're the owners of traditional ops
like keep the servers up kind of stuff
but they also are responsible for like
nsq and a lot of our database stuff and
even some kind of internal tooling stuff
and our bias is very much towards hiring
engineers who grew to system and stuff
than
the other way around
um so
for us it's not like we we very much try
and avoid situations where we're we're
in the mindset of where we're throwing
over the wall
right it's very much a shared
responsibility kind of
attitude
which does actually get to the next bit
of how we approach things as far as how
we handle architecture and planning
um this is another place where you can
very easily get into a place where you
get very draconian and very things feel
heavy and it's hard to do stuff
but we try and keep what we try and
uh remain diligent while keeping to like
weight and the way we do that is
basically by asking a series of
questions you know there's no like
binder questions right like i'm
literally going to go through the
questions we ask and this is often for
takes the form of like some ops people
and some other people who are involved
in the project
sitting in front of a white board and
having a conversation like this is like
an hour long exercise it's not
huge
uh the first thing that we usually ask
is how is this going to be backwards
compatible
right um if there are any kind of both
well public-facing api changes are a
whole other beast
largely in that you can't do them
at least breaking changes at least not
easily
something we've learned over the years
if you publish an api people will make
calls
matching that api until the end of time
how much you care about may be a
different question but they will make
those calls
anyway
internally everything has to be accuracy
compatible
uh and the main reason for that is
deploys aren't instant right
as a practical reality if you're
deploying to a cluster of two dozen
servers
it's not going to happen at once you're
going to have at least two versions of
code existing in production at the same
time those have to be able to play nice
with each other
and most of the time making that
backwards compatibility work isn't too
bad it's just one of those things you
have to think of up front
similarly
having that backwards compatibility in
place makes rollouts and
roll backs and bailouts are much easier
right if things are backwards compatible
with how they were
just making everything back to how it
was
it's probably fine
the next thing
is that we think about is how are we
going to do this without downtime
um there may have been one or two small
exceptions at some point in middle east
history but at this point for us outages
for
system updates are not okay
excuse me
um
willing to do a fair amount of work
to make sure that we can do it
uh you know makes whatever change we
need to make without downtime
but most of the time it's actually not
as bad as it seems especially when you
have that soa kind of setup
and especially if this is the interfaces
between the systems you're dealing with
are those asynchronous cues
everything gets much easier an example
here is
um
we have this like user history system
that's based on this charted setup
and
it
basically
wasn't going to scale as it was set up
so what we're able to do is stand up a
new cluster
copy have the rights get copied so we're
dual writing into both systems and
that's easy to do with nsq
move data over from the old system to
the new one from before the time we
started dual writing
and then once that's done
just move over the reads as we want
right so that's when we had no downtime
even no right outage we completely moved
from one physical cluster to another and
it's completely transparent to users and
it wasn't that like it was more work
certainly but it wasn't that much more
work for us um and again it's one of
those things where when you ask that
question upfront
like building the system then go
realizing oh
wow this is going to cause us trouble
how do we deal with it right
the next thing that comes up and this is
where a lot of just kind of the
different perspectives of different
people and different teams comes in
is asking how are we going to know
something broken
right what monitoring does this need
what um
you know what nagios checks does this
need what stash should be collected
hey if it breaks am i going to get paged
if i get paged how am i going to know
what to do
all that gets asked up front
and to beat a dead horse
when you ask that up front it's much
easier to deal with than when you're
about to deploy the system and then
somebody goes hey so if that crown job
doesn't run what happens
right
um
um partially so usually from a
systematic level that conversation
happens before there's even any code
written so there'll be a high level
thing of like okay well we know
we're going to have this database
involved and we're going to have these
processes involved and they'll have to
be this thing happening periodically
so we'll develop basically as part of
the requirements for the system
know that we'll have to have checks here
here and there
but then
potentially
the main place where that checklist gets
involved is let's say
so actually in the case of
that system switchover i was
talking about
what that checklist would have consisted
of would be the steps of like okay so
we're going to bring up the new system
we're going to start doing rights into
that system we're going to do the
whatever steps we need to copy over the
data and then we're going to switch
reads and then we're going to do this to
get confidence that the rates will work
we're like everything's working right
and then we'll kill the old system like
that's what would be in that checklist
for the most part i mean there's
different levels like that that one's
pretty involved a lot of times what
we'll do what the checklist for the
smaller stuff will consist of
is um
what the validation steps are right so
there are ways things can break which
won't necessarily set off checks right
like if some css is kind of
at least with our current testing that's
probably not going to set off an alert
but it'll piss off a user um so we
define what those checks look like
so um so you use jenkins from build and
what are sort of the things you to check
uh i'll get to that
um
and actually this touches a little bit
on i'll get into a bit more now um but
so kind of continuing on that
um
once we know something's broken
what do we have to have in place to
figure out what's wrong right what needs
to be logged
what needs to where is that logging
going and what has to go into uh our
stats system uh right at say we use
graphite
a lot
i forget the exact number but we're
in the billions if not tens of billions
of increments a day for our graphite
cluster
um
so
again when i get that page at 4 o'clock
in the morning and i get alert saying
hey this thing's broken
what's the next step how do i figure out
where to go next
um
what operational options are there for
dealing with failures right so different
systems are going to look different ways
when they fall down or
when systems they care about go down
right so
let's say a box
for a particular service goes down does
that mean that we need to pause cues so
we don't lose data
while we handle reprovision in the box
or
is a particular class of machine
stateless if we just spin up a new box
right like
what what what do those failure
scenarios look like and how do we deal
with that and where do i find that
information is kind of questions up with
that
um
next question is how available does the
system need to be
one of the other nice things about an
soa type system
is we can have different availability
guarantees for different services
so as an example our decode service
has massive redundancy built into it
we're at the place where even if our
primary data center literally falls off
the face of the planet we could be up
and redirecting within a few minutes
right
on the other hand some of our like our
hadoop cluster which is primarily used
for research tasks at this point
if it goes down for an hour
it's not awesome some people are going
to be kind of annoyed internally but
not the end of the world we don't need
to spend more resources making that more
available um so we we kind of have that
conversation about kind of cost benefits
both in times literal costs of actual
hardware as well as like dev time and
and
attention
um and then
i guess i kind of had that redundantly
anyway again pay a lot of attention to
failure scenarios because that's
where stuff gets squirrely oh sorry this
is speaking to um
how failure of other systems is going to
deal with it how can we route around
failure right so if this is querying
another system and one of the boxes in
that system goes weird what impact is
that going to have and how do we deal
with that one of the ways we deal with
that is we have a library called
hostpool it's open source this one's
python somewhere we have a go one i
forgot what the link is you can probably
find it
um
and the idea there is you can kind of
think of it at an
application load balancer
in the sense of uh the way it works is
you'll say instead of saying this is the
uh just url i want to query for the
other system you can say that um this is
the pool of servers i want to query for
a system so when you do a query you ask
for a server to query you do it you do
your query and then when you get the
response you either say that worked or
it didn't
and the library then kind of in memory
just keeps track of those success rates
and then increases the probability that
healthy servers will get queried
effectively allows things to self-heal
and self-route around failures
obviously you want to have moderating in
place to know when that happens because
self-healing only goes so far and having
brooklyn stuff out there is not great
long term but
it helps you know deal with stuff while
you're figuring while the slow humans
are figuring out what's going on
uh similarly nsq has a lot of capacity
for routing around failure
but again if you're interested i can
talk about later
uh what hardware will this require again
kind of going back to the soa discussion
um
can this be okay on a c1 medium or do we
need
ssds do we need more memory what do we
need here
uh and similarly is what this is going
to be doing going to justify the costs
associated with that
what uh have discussed at least have an
understanding of what's involved in
adding capacity
a lot of times we'll build systems so
that you know for the next six months
we'll be fine
but what's going to happen if either we
get more traffic than we expected or
those six months go up
right um sometimes it can be nice and
like if it's just a nice stateless
service it's the answer is throw more
hardware at it awesome great throwing
money at the problems is
always a fantastic answer
um but other times it's harder right
like if you have just a mysql database
throwing hardware at it is kind of not
easy to do right so what does that
process look like and if not having the
tooling in place right now
understanding and documenting what the
avenues are for a given system
is important for us
again similarly there's often when we're
building new services
uh asking these questions up front allow
us to make relatively easy to make
changes from an architectural standpoint
that um when asked at the beginning make
things down the road much easier
but if you did later in the process
it would involve like
stuff right
uh we also since we run into data
centers we have the question of what
data centers should this run in
um there's a certain amount of
there's some situations where cost
performance is better for the physical
hardware than the
virtual in particular ram and disk space
is a lot better for the physical for us
for cpu-bound stuff it's kind of the
same
actually the bigger thing for us often
is
understanding what other services this
is going to be chatting with um so if
there's another service that this thing
is going with this new service is going
to be chatting with it will probably be
nice to not have that chinese going over
public networks
and just staying on a lan so a lot of
times we'll try and co-locate services
that
rely on each other a lot
uh similarly what kind of relatedly what
we ask what impact
a new service is going to have on other
systems
right if something's going to be
increasing the load on the system by 10x
that other system's probably going to
care about that
right so we have to work through the
implications of that again most of the
time not too bad if we ask it up front
but if you didn't ask the question
launched it and all of a sudden that
system has 10x to load
that's probably not going to be an
awesome day
uh and the last question we try and ask
is will there be any ongoing operational
tasks obviously we try and build systems
so that they more or less take care of
themselves but sometimes especially for
the first one or two iterations of a
system it makes sense to just have an
ops test happen every six months right
um we have a system that like archives
the raw data that will crawl off the
internet and it turns out doing out uh
exploration of billions of things is
really really hard just computationally
and the easiest solution we've found is
just to have those that like crawl cache
off a bunch of ebs mounts and every
couple of months just format one of
those mounts and
call it done right like
it's just there and we just at this
point like it's a rare enough thing
that's easy enough that it just hasn't
made sense to build the tooling for
but we want to understand that and make
sure we're doing that cost trade-off
uh equation of do we need to build a
tooling to automate this or can just be
an operational task for now
i'll bang back to the gentleman's
question
monitoring
the scary stuff that's going to wake us
up in the middle of the night
uh so for
uh learning we use nagios
it is bizarre it is byzantine it
literally takes you eight months to
figure out where an earth stuff is in
the interface
but it is solid as a rock and once you
damage your brain to understand it it's
fine
at least for us like we have enough
grizzled grey beard ops people that they
knew this off the bat it was the easy
answer for us
if it's not nagios you need something
that when something breaks we'll notice
him wake you up because uh i forget who
to attribute this to but there's a great
quote of if you don't have a nagios
check on something it is probably broken
you just don't know about it yet
if you're not actively checking things
and making sure they're doing what you
think they are doing
uh it's almost certainly broken in some
way something actually that's
interesting that we've done
started to do more aggressive recently
is in addition to doing kind of the
obvious nagios checks of is of is stuff
up uh are server metrics within normal
bounds right we're not swapping out or
whatever
uh we've actually started adding data
integrity checks into nagios as well
um
we've actually run into situations where
services
will be up and look like they're
operating right but be telling you dirty
filthy lies when you ask them things
and that's obviously not great so we
added august checks to make sure that's
not happening
so i'm gonna think about uh graphite
again we're at etsy thank you
we use this a ton
pretty much anything that we care about
in aggregate
we we add metrics on a lot of times we
even just
instrument stuff and graphite just
because
um it might be interesting uh we
actually spent a decent money on our
graphic cluster but that's because we
throw a lot at it uh and then we also
are then able to pull that data into
other things very easily so this example
blackboard that's basically just a
health of our api right it's just kind
of stuff you would expect right unknown
errors per minute uh 99 times 95 percent
times if you look down in the mean times
in there again if any of those are going
up into the right or if there's a big
spike in there somewhere you probably
want to look at it because stuff's broke
um
this is actually the kind of stuff that
we're starting to
work on adding physical just like
dashboards and like tvs into our office
so you have that awareness of like oh
hey you know you're just going to get
coffee and go oh hey there's a big spike
10 minutes ago in our main response time
what's that about
you know
digging into that um centralized
searchable logs are really powerful
right now we have a ghetto wrapper on
wrap
uh hopefully soon we'll be switching to
log stash and cabana basically like an
open source um splunk
but that's where we are today
under the set covers syslog getting
everything to one place but having
everything like
uh all your public requests into bitly
go into a cluster of two dozen servers
uh if one of them is having errors
figuring out which one of them is gonna
take some time if you have to log into
each of them individually having your
logs in one central place where you can
search things is pretty powerful
and to wrap things up some quick final
thoughts
um be deliberate make sure
you're you're doing things for a
specific reason and not just throwing
at the wall
kind of the same vein understand why
you're doing something like it's really
easy to just
look up the
yeah
uh the random searches on flickr for uh
creative commons stuff is fantastic
if you
it's really easy to like have a problem
do the stack overflow search and find a
solution but not take that extra step to
understand why that solution addresses
your problem
take that extra step it really
pays off big big time
certainly work through the details and
obviously there are limits on all this
if you take this to an extreme you'll
just be digging into like how your com
your specific compiler and processor are
working and that's probably not
productive
most of the time but maybe go a layer or
two deeper than you absolutely have to
to understand what's going on it really
both helps further you as a developer
and make sure that you are doing what
you actually need to be doing
and finally a quick shameless plug
uh bitly shockingly we're hiring we
really want to talk to you we'd love to
talk to you
come talk to me afterwards or check out
buttley.com jobs
uh and if that any questions
uh logistics and cabana so logstash you
can kind of think as like a thing that
routes streams of logs and makes it easy
to push stuff into elasticsearch and
cabana is like a ui on top of
elasticsearch that's optimized for logs
we've had some quirks implementing it
but that's more quirks of our
infrastructure and those particular
tools
uh sure um
so sorry i've been doing a bad job of
this i should be repeating the questions
so the question is obviously bitly
hasn't always been doing this how do we
get here
um and if there's been any particular
critical moments in that path
um
oh for better and worse actually a lot
of this was already in place when i
joined bentley at least from a high
level
um
a lot of it has been
a matter of having a culture of
caring about process but also having an
analogy to enterprisiness
right and that definitely creates
tension right there a lot of times when
something goes wrong there's a very easy
answer of developing a process to
not do that again right but if you do
that all the time and take that easy
answer you end up with this like that's
how you end up with like
the crazy like
you know enterprising world type stuff
right
so a lot of it basically comes down to
caring about process
like and thinking about things in those
terms
being willing to take the time to figure
out if there is
a
using this word but more elegant
solution than just
making process to not do that again
um
and doing things iteratively
um something else that's kind of
interesting of this for especially like
lean
type folks
uh it wasn't i don't think done
in quite that intentional of a way but
just intuitively as the way we work
virtually none of this was done like
as a fundamental change and by fiat a
lot of it has just been kind of
incrementally done as needed over time
as the team's grown
um
i don't know if that answers but
cool i think there was a question in the
back
uh so this is again a place where i
suspect we're cheating by our size
uh right now there's just one on-call
rotation
and whoever's on call gets the alerts
period
we have started to talk and think about
potentially having more
directed ownership like that but we
haven't gone there yet
and for the most part
thankfully it's relatively rare that
um
new systems break at four o'clock in the
morning i guess via the rest of our
process and
doing stuff like doing partial like
especially for back-end systems a lot of
times part of our validation process
like let's say i'm uh rolling out
changing how a particular like
user-facing api is implemented that
doesn't have any functional changes to
the user but changes how we do things
internally a lot of times we'll just
deploy that to one or two servers let it
soak for a day and then push it out like
doing stuff like that
makes it pretty rare that new systems
cause problems at four o'clock in the
morning
uh
yes thank you um so the question is how
we are actually deploying
um
how to describe it uh
so like i said it's a home-grown system
that
uh when you kind of squint hard enough
and look at a high enough level of
abstraction looks a lot like chef and
puppet
uh the particularly interesting way
that's the case is there's basically a
series of tags that define
what a series should be which then run a
series of item potent install scripts
uh
that will basically
like
the the tags will basically say like um
so the process that does redirects for
us is called nsd right so we'll have a
tag that says nsd should be running on
this box it should have like n like four
pro copies of that process running right
so the install script will basically go
through and say like okay is the version
that i expect installed in the box
uh yes great i'll just move on and not
care uh no okay let me do whatever i
gotta do to get the box closer to the
desired state
at that level is pretty standard
how we actually go about implementing it
it's basically a giant pile of ash with
some tools to make it easier to do the
item code and stuff
and most of the time we try and work
with whatever environments tool chain
the python stuff is a little
non-standard but that's mostly just
because like a lot of why this stuff is
homegrown is not because the existing
tools
are inadequate it's just they didn't
exist when the stuff was built
and like the migrating cost is not
justified um but yeah we a lot of our
binary stuff gets installed by rpm we're
running centos
like five something in most places
um a lot of stuff we just run our own
binaries for um but a lot of python
stuff gets a fairly standard install
um
i just use those examples and that uh
that that approach of basically
having something that defines what a
server should be and then having a
series of important scripts
to get it closer to that state is
roughly architecturally what our system
looks like
uh the actual implementation that is
bit more about just approach to soa so
obviously if you break your system down
to a lot of small very simple services
those services individually very simple
but if you have to join lots of moving
parts together there's potentially
potentially architectural complexity
there which gives rise
sure uh so to paraphrase the question
how do we manage complexity in soa
uh on the system side
we get to cheat a ton because our data
is effective the lion's share of our
data is is important uh immutable right
so the fact that we don't have to deal
with changes or deletes makes a whole
lot of problems way easier right because
denormalization at that point is
dumb simple right like you just get a
copy of all the
rights that happen and you're done it's
easy it's great
um so there are a lot of things where we
just
don't have that problem which is
somewhat cheating on our part or just
maybe not cheating but taking advantage
of the situation we're in it definitely
is more complicated situation for other
people
um we do run into some of that as far as
joining data sets right so actually a
lot of the
quirks in the existing bitly interface
as far as like well why can't i just
filter my links by this that and the
other thing the answer is because that's
in five different systems and doing
joins across databases is
not a thing
um and so the answer there is usually if
we have to do a new kind of combination
of data that means a new service
as far as managing complexity from a
tooling standpoint
um
it's a lot of basically self-discipline
there definitely was a phase of bitly
where we had a database of the week
problem
at this point we basically have all the
open source databases except for
postgres and even now that we have
redshift we have a weirdo flavor of that
um
but
releasing the time that i've been there
we've done pretty good about
uh
effectively
if
somebody proposes using a new data store
or a new language or a new platform
um asking the hard questions to justify
it right so
um and actually that's one thing i
really like about bitly is their
the culture is very much in a place
where
making those proposals is totally okay
but you better be able to justify your
position right if you want to bring in a
new database you better be able to damn
well explain why one of the ones that we
already have a bunch of experience in
tooling in place
are inadequate
similarly if you want to bring in a new
language or platform
you have to be able to answer those
kinds of questions
um
we've also started at least for
databases
i don't think we intentionally did it
but it's kind of happened uh if you
bring in a new database you're on the
on-call rotation
uh so that also kind of helps
keep people using what's there
but yeah it definitely is a struggle
that's something we have to work with
cool
uh sorry i'll get the side and then
uh
so
we're lazy and we have an unbelievable
java slash jvm allergy at
bitly sorry so the question was uh how
do we actually handle getting the commit
status stuff back out of jenkins
uh so we have this
bordering on irrational jvm allergy at
bitly a lot of it comes down to just
getting burned a few times in the past
and then not being lazy and not wanting
to have to learn how to do jvm tuning
because we don't have experience in that
uh accordingly
for certain styles of that workflow
there are plugins for jenkins that'll
just do it
we ran into some quirks and that since
we do so many like we try and keep our
pull requests small
accordingly i think we're up to issue
number
forget we're in like the 2500s on github
um
and uh just as a quark is gig as github
implements ways to actually pull down
that pull request code uh it breaks a
lot of the
existing plugins uh so we basically have
a sidecar service that uses the github
um
commit hook api and then jenkins has a
similar thing where you can subscribe to
notifications about things that happen
inside of jenkins now basically handling
the messaging back and forth you
entirely could implement it as a jenkins
plugin but we're
hating java so
i think there's a question over here
yep um so there's some interesting there
the question uh to repeat it was
um basically what does our staging
environment look like and what it
transitions from dev to station prod
look like
um
so we have some interesting quirks in
there
uh the most prominent of which is for us
staging is generally staging of code not
of data
so our staging environment actually
queries production databases and
production
back-end systems in a lot of cases
a lot of the reason for that is to
basically deal with the soa complexity
issue um one of the drawbacks of an soa
setup is it's
unbelievably difficult
to have a consistent subset of data
across your entire system
right because since your data is split
into
let's call it three dozen services
they each have their own
snapshot or slice of
the data that the system overall has
therefore getting a consistent slice of
that to have a subset of that
infrastructure for full on our like
normal staging environment is extremely
difficult
and uh running a mirror setup
since we see like i said uh i think it
works out to about 3000 d codes per
second as like a normal stream like
having the staging system that can
handle that is basically doubling our
servers and we just can't afford that
right now so we have the quirk of that
weird staging it's just code not data
most of the time it works out okay our
dev environments are
we just use uh
vms so we actually use the same
deployment infrastructure
all the way from dev up to production we
try and keep our dev and staging
environments as close to production as
possible obviously with the exception of
actual like network separation kind of
issues and hardware capacity
um
and the way the promotion process works
is basically
um
developers will work on the local vm
get it to a place where they think
excuse me it's useful
push that up to github
they'll start running in jenkins jenkins
runs against effectively dead
environments
um
then uh we have we use hipchat
internally so we have a hip chatbot
uh i think it's based off a hubot where
you can reserve staging
uh if you need to you can push your code
there we do we have started to we've
gone to a size where we started to run
into some issues on staging contention
so we're probably gonna have to figure
out a different approach for that soon
we're not we're still working through
what that's gonna look like
for front end code there is still some
manual testing we don't have any formal
qa people
some of that's by design some of that
we're desperately trying to hire people
the design part is
we're fairly against the idea of having
humans who their
specific job is to just go and click on
things
uh that's just
both if we want to do as many deploys as
we want to do that's too slow too
inconsistent and just
people-wise like those are salaries that
can go elsewhere
so we really focus on automation of
testing
uh so we're really trying to hire
basically a lead qa engineer to help
build out that infrastructure to be
better than it is
particularly around front end code right
now our front-end testing is not where
it needs to be
um
but they're accordingly the
to deal with that the
a lot of times when a code change goes
out that affects front end stuff the
developer as well as other people on the
team they'll say like hey it goes up on
stage and go check it out we'll do some
manual testing that goes live but most
of us relying on um
uh
uh it depends i mean so a lot of those
pushes are might be operational stuff it
might be back-end stuff those the
automated testing is much better
coverage in which case you don't have to
deal with the manual testing
so it kind of depends
uh there's a question over here and then
i'll
oh yeah
so using tools like jenkins which are
great but they're only as good as the
developer's tests so do you have do you
do some type of analysis that checks how
much of the code that's kind of code
coverage before you accept it
as good enough to actually be pushed up
like what if somebody built something
and you decided
uh
yeah so the question is basically
who tests the testers
how do we have confidence in the test
the automated testing infrastructure
uh right now we don't rely too much on
cover coverage metrics um it's basically
a manual part of the
uh peer review process so the review
absolutely includes tests
and
a fair portion of time at least the
reviews i do are like hey so tests about
those
um or like obviously if there are tests
in the poll request already having
questions about like how is this
covering things is
focused enough does it broadly handle
stuff
one of the things that
we're still struggling a bit with that
again makes is kind of hard in the sos
environment is kind of integration
versus unit tests
and the value of each of those um so
we're still kind of working through some
getting more consistent about some of
that but
mostly it's the peer review process and
um
culture and shame
if you have something that doesn't have
tests then you get shamed
um
so i was just curious you mentioned like
operational changes versus code changes
um
i guess this might be a case of bitly
vocabulary leaking out to the outside
world
um so the question was uh i've been
talking about operational changes versus
code changes and what does that mean
uh so i apologize for that internal
vocabulary leaking
um not that it's
precious or anything it just doesn't
mean anything to anybody else it's
mostly the intent or the purpose of a
change
i guess is where that kind of ends up
falling out so i mean i mean i have an
idea
i'm just curious
sure so examples of that i guess a lot
of comes down to
who on what teams are doing stuff and
why they're doing it so example would be
um
a change we made recently uh is so
the authoritative database of what a
short link to a long url and vice versa
is basically this big chart of my sql
cluster doing application level sharding
and that cluster started to run out of
space
happens after five years
so we had to grow that and
when you're growing charting that
usually is not trivial uh so there were
significant code changes involved to
grow that cluster that was largely
viewed as something that the ops
infrastructure team was owning and so on
so that might be a case of what i was
talking about there okay
um question is is would somebody
operationally make a change on an
individual server or would they
basically push a change to a group of
services
uh
so effectively it's always the latter
the group might happen to consist of one
server but we almost
i'm sure there's some exit
exception somewhere that's happened
but if somebody were to ssh onto a
server and change the code locally
they would be shamed to oblivion at
bitly like that's just not a thing
everything happens through sem
everything happens through git
everything happens to the deploy process
a lot of that has to do with that kind
of joint state stuff of having to have
that history and have that
consistent view of the world um
a lot of it also has to do with like we
we really rely on that documentation
right like
being able to go back and see when
things were changed is
like
if i went onto a server and found code
that didn't match the git commit that's
checked out there like there is a deep
issue and whoever did that is having
like we're having a conversation right
like that's just
how we do stuff
um
and a lot of it comes down to
when you have so many people touching so
many different pieces of a system if you
can't go back and have that basically
audit trail like things become
unmanageable very quickly
change management yes
that's our current form of change
uh the peer review with the
button rule
uh by far that is my
my favorite thing about how we do things
at bitly and the thing that
really enables a lot of the other stuff
uh whoever wrote the code is not allowed
to merge the code
uh so everything happens through pull
requests and i mean everything
nobody makes commits to master
unless we like somebody literally broke
it and we're fixing it
which has happened maybe
twice
um
and
uh
for us
there's a lot of ways where we're able
to avoid process through discipline
and that process is the mechanism for
having institutional discipline
if that makes sense
uh
it was i think there was a question over
here quick
yeah
that's an interesting question the
question was uh how do we decide on a
feature in an existing service versus
building a new service
a lot of it for us comes down to
how data needs to be persisted and how
it needs to be queried
when you get to scale bitly
for a lot of things
the only way to have
reasonable user queries is to
pre-aggregate things
so that's what a lot of our systems are
doing doing various forms of
pre-aggregations like basically
um like for your click count of bitly
we're not doing select count star
because that database would have
uh
hundreds of billions of things in it at
this point and that's
not a query that's going to happen in
request response cycle
at least in a user uh for us uh so and
accordingly we kind of increment
counters as the clicks come in and then
we just tell you what the counter says
uh so a lot of it comes down to yeah
basically that equation of like
does this fit within a persistence in a
query model that an existing system has
and makes sense in that realm of roles
and responsibilities and if not then it
means a new service
and new services are not
uncommon or
a high barrier for us we probably create
a few every well not every month every
few months
um i i know i keep on going i don't know
if you guys have any kind of time i'm
happy to keep going but
sure so
so you have a solid process and it works
well for you so based on what's working
and what's not what's next this is just
incremental things like better
usability testing or are there big
things that you want to do um yeah it's
an interesting question um
i guess with an ops focus
one of the biggest things for us is that
staging condition issue uh we actually
are starting to run into situations
where devs are sitting around twirling
their thumbs for unacceptable periods of
time waiting for station to become
available
so we're really starting to try and work
through that uh we have some capacity
issues just
systems that were built a while ago that
were you know intentionally designed
with certain limitations that we're
starting to run up against so we just
have to make changes to deal with that
um
we've mostly worked through with the
current issues with it but the ddos
stuff has been really big for the last
i guess actually since january we've
been dealing with a number of ddos
attacks and
getting that process down huh you
shouldn't help me out
we've actually been talking to some
other people who have been getting hit
um yeah it's tough
um yeah if anybody's interested in
talking about some of that stuff i'd be
happy to talk about that afterwards but
uh yeah it sucks just that's all there
is
um is there another question
awesome cool you all have been great
thank you